[Applause]
let's toast to you not being pregnant if
you're not pregnant then we [ __ ] my
goodness
i can't believe that mariah carey is
opening up about this
uncomfortable 2008 appearance on the
ellen degeneres show
who knows what they hold who knows all
right go ahead
okay cheers cheers the clip of ellen
trying to pressure the singer
into drinking champagne as a way to
offset pregnancy rumors
recently resurfaced on twitter following
allegations of a toxic
workplace environment on the show people
are saying
that that you're pregnant there there's
rumors
don't discuss that um all right well you
don't have to
that's okay no honestly let's just toast
with champagne
now in an interview with vulture mariah
is addressing that extremely
uncomfortable moment with degeneres
telling the mag that she's
really had a quote hard time grappling
with the aftermath
i can have some champagne it's just
fattening you can't have champagne
that's not champagne because you can no
it is
the singer who married then-husband nick
cannon about
six months prior to her sit-down with
ellen did
everything she could to dodge the tv
personality's persistence
you want to taste it i can't believe you
did this to me ellen what
no are you trying i'm not gonna ask you
if you're pregnant this is peer pressure
you see what ellen is doing this is peer
pressure i was like why does she keep
talking about chip
at one point mariah even claimed it was
too early to drink
just before appearing to take a small
sip
go ahead okay cheers cheers it's too
early for me i only drink it
after 3 p.m yeah
here's the thing the 50 year old legend
who has appeared on the show five times
since
actually was pregnant at the time but
she tells vulture
that she wasn't ready to announce the
news because she'd previously suffered a
miscarriage
i can't say what's next or what's not
next for me
so many things are happening of the
interview mariah stresses that she
doesn't want to throw
anyone that's already being thrown under
the proverbial bus
but she says she didn't enjoy that
moment
adding that there's an empathy that can
be applied to those moments
than i would have liked to have been
implemented i'm trying to tone it down
carrie ended up suffering another
miscarriage shortly after her 2008 ellen
interview
but went on to welcome twins moreau and
monrocken with cannon
in 2011. all i can say is they're my
life
they make me happy and if none of these
other things were going on they'd still
be
everything to me